[Music]
welcome to the h3 podcast extravaganza
that's right we're an extravaganza now
thank you to 23andme
posts mates and hims for sponsoring us
and thank you to everybody for joining
us today on this beautiful blessed
Friday
boy do I love Fridays we started taking
the weekends off and I just kidding
Fridays now mmm
happy Friday to everyone watching we've
got a lot to discuss today we're very
excited we've got some Chane updates
we've got some Pappajohn updates we've
got some buffing updates we've talked
previously about a guru for goofus slap
a slap a boo from goombah slap and Ian
the intern has prepared for us one of
his notorious and much celebrated
PowerPoint presentation on deciphering
the meaning of Kanye West wow that's a
big task oh but I know it wasn't up for
it but before we get into all that I've
got a little announcement not really an
announcement just something I wanted to
talk about but it may be that ela is is
there's a new thing of the thickening it
was gonna be thickening up here soon
what does that mean what I'm trying to
say is that ela won't be drinking
alcohol if she's responsible what I'm
trying to say read podcast extra no
that's me sorry I how long is that going
oh it just started like just now you
turned it off of me okay and flashback
[Laughter]
there's two stripes she's cooking
something up anyone it's a cinnamon roll
with frosting man yeah it's weird
[Laughter]
there's something going on
[Music]
well it's we we don't know yet if
anything's gonna go wrong she's pregnant
less pregnant I have been I've been
squirting an ela for years I mean I'm
just going frankly like we've been I've
been I've been you know what I'm saying
and depend on we've talked about it a
lot on the podcast so it's a natural
extension of our efforts to get ela
knocked up and I have been a fully
unsheathed about New Year's dick has
been out and flirting we did the test we
did everything but I'll say that we got
what happened naturally in just the good
old-fashioned way he had sex yeah you
know I know it is gross I don't know I
don't know I don't feel about it well
just like two days ago two days ago we
found out yeah and ela she would admit
was a couple of days late on her period
and her boobs were raw how would you say
tender what your boobs were tender it
just hurts I don't know get some tender
s pity but anyway that's like what
happens when you're getting in the
period and I remember it was like a week
earlier like oh I'm getting my period
yeah and the night before I was like
maybe you're pregnant jokingly yeah and
I was like actually I already checked
and it was negative all right but it
wasn't your first idea the more didn't
do it right yeah yeah but it's
interesting cuz the last two months we
kind of didn't really try we're like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] whatever if it happens it
happens and we're just not gonna pay
attention and of course that's when it
happened so funny yeah of course and I
don't wanna feel about I'm scared I
don't know how they feel about it it's
terrifying I'm more scared than
you cuz you gotta [ __ ] it yeah I have
utmost respect for that I'm telling you
that and people always say like don't
tell until I don't know for months I
don't know it's like it but then you're
gonna see that I'm pregnant
like was just superstitious yeah or but
you had a really good point about
because people think that maybe
something will go wrong but it's like if
that happens then why I'm not supposed
to talk about it like it's a secret
yeah exactly you just carry this like
sad thing yeah I'm good and you don't
tell you can't because I guess the
theory is I think first of all people
are superstitious mm-hmm second of all
for those that don't know in the first
like I don't know couple months it's
very common that you can have a
miscarriage and I didn't know don't know
yeah because it's like you don't talk
about it why not talk about like you'll
say when you're sick he'll talk about it
yeah or if you have to do a surgery so
why is that like oh you're right and
it's a it's a sad thing it's a
vulnerable thing and it's kind of sucks
to just carry that silently with you I
mean yeah but I I guess the theory is
that yeah people probably just are
superstitious about it and then yeah
maybe it happens sometimes people have
like many miscarriages
mm-hmm it could happen like five times
and you're like oh [ __ ] I got to do this
whole thing like but ELA approach me a
couple days ago and she's like eath I
was in bed just looking at the news or
something
she's like Ethan we got a problem or
something and I didn't answer for a
minute yeah just kind of groggy you said
something like two stripes yeah and I
was like no way yeah when I did the test
I felt like I felt like there's no way
like oh yeah y-you know the boys can
swim
it's good to know though because it was
kind of where I was worried that you
know you worried that's what's wrong
what's going on
you know why can't I I can't why can't
they
it ended up taking birth control like
maybe almost two years ago at this plant
so it could be that can take a while
yeah but so my so it worked the boys can
swim the girls can catch and the team is
functioning
you know ela started like a week ago
before we knew she was preggers she was
like I'm hungry like yeah she started
eating she had pizza and she's like and
I have to tell you this but this was
shitty pizza and I'm not one to say that
because pizza and my opinions like sex
when it's good it's great and when it's
bad it's pretty good but no I'm like
this pizza is kind of sucky and he'll is
like really this is the best pizza I've
ever had and I'm just not that good but
I think elos starting to get hungry
yeah even happens that early but I can't
I have been I don't know we said you
feel something going on in your stomach
yeah
feel like things are moving in my
stomach it's a [ __ ] baby dude so
anyway so guys don't tell anyone
yeah don't tell anyone please until 10
weeks it's between all of us and I don't
know how to feel about it and we've been
trying for a while but I was like just
so used to not getting pregnant I was
like oh cool I was like cool man [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
but now how am I gonna take care of a
kid when I'm so dysfunctional ela
believes I mean that's all that matters
well anyway Neil is pregnant so there
you have it that long yep thank you that
is true that's how I feel so we thought
we'd share that happy news with
everybody and thank you for joining us
on this blessed Friday to share this
beautiful wonderful news me inside
internally
[Laughter]
let's move on we've got Shane now the
Shane documentary we had talked about in
a previous episode and I give Shane all
the credit in the world I mean this guy
has pioneered a new form of content on
you okay and he's had this incredible
fan base and he the numbers are just
like unfresh that has six hundred
thousand likes when a tweet yeah what is
going on yeah it's wild so I mean
obviously hats off to the to the guy
he's a friend of the show even though
even though even though he betrayed me
after all we've been through okay cut
you were not yet we'll get there nyah
let's at least get into a little bit
before the Papa father yeah exactly and
reliving the memory of that great
betrayal anyway so he goes on as we
touched on in the last step so the chain
starts exploring this theory what if
Logan is the sociopath and Jake is
living in the shadow of Logan the
sociopath took a weird turn
we just all became about it who is a
sociopath and right like well the next
episode was him sitting for like 40 or
50 minutes with a therapist and super
dramatic kind of she's really dramatic
it's kind of trying to diagnose him and
anyway Logan Paul made a response video
and I mean a lot of people have been
criticizing Shane for his kind of the
way that he's been trying to diagnose
him because he does this funny anything
that's there he's a really good at yeah
where they created this like horror they
create an atmosphere attention and that
it was very good they're good at it but
it's like you're also talking about
something serious you're talking about a
real person you're talking about mental
health and we know it's big Paul logo
Paul which are like the - you know Daria
YouTube but regardless I'm not even
trying to make a serious point about
channel I don't I honestly I'm not here
to refute or talk about any I honestly
Logan Paul made a response video and
it's given us through us all here one of
the best gems that have ever come across
this platform and so this to me was what
was most important to share with you
guys
I'll let Logan speak for himself now he
he goes on the record he's and he
actually says I'm not a sociopath but I
do have sociopathic tendencies which is
interesting it sounds like he's been
diagnosed the way he talks about it
because he's very knowledgeable and he
goes you're not either a sociopath or
not a sociopath it's a sliding scale and
some people have more sociopathic
tendencies
yeah others but he goes on to say
something that really resonated with me
and made me really understand what he
meant by that so I'll share it with you
guys now there's a sociopathic mark jobs
no Steve Zuckerberg Mark Zuckerberg and
Steve Jobs a lot of people especially
youtubers and strain touched on this you
can't just say like you're a sociopath
the word I would like to use is
sociopathic tendencies so a lot of us me
included
we'll do some thumb should be some stuff
that lacks empathy strictly for views
right it gets us views which gets the
subscribers a motivating factor is to
reach the next next next level sociopath
is boil down someone who is just more
savage than everyone else I know it
sounds so that's it
I mean that's pretty much a clinical
definition of sociopaths somebody who is
more savage than everybody else and I
think Logan for that definition and I
just think and I'm just happy that
that's in the world Logan Paul saying
it's just someone that's more savage
than everybody else
double dab double dab will do ya
motivating factor is to reach the next
next next level sociopath is boil down
someone who is just more savage than
everyone else I know it sounds I just
I have double with that I'm having
trouble with comparisons I was making it
cool for his fans cuz they're always
like savage yeah that's what so savage
means cool right in his world yeah so a
sociopath I think a case antisocial
personality disorder which is someone
that lacks empathy someone who has a
Jenner I mean there again I'm not gonna
do it's not a it's not generally it's
not I want to call it sad come on call
it savage necessarily you know maybe a
psycho and then Ethan did you go to
psychology school cuz I am NOT a I am
NOT a trained professional it sounds to
me it does some very clinical yeah that
it sounds like something you're here in
a classroom this whole argument though
that between him and Shane like it's
just I feel like which shouldn't be this
whole thing about self diagnosing and I
feel like even Logan's definition is
wrong because I was trying to read about
it online and educate myself a little
bit before I came into this podcast and
apparently sociopathy isn't even a
clinical term the real clinical term is
antisocial personality disorder and it's
just this whole messy thing I don't like
that it's just I don't know but everyone
always just googling and self-diagnose
yeah and like but anyway Logan's
defending himself he does make a lot of
good points in here but a sociopath is
basically some of this more savage so
I'm gonna add that's through the wiki
page yeah essentially we need to add
that to the clinical definition but it's
someone that lacks empathy someone's
very manipulative someone that doesn't I
mean they lack empathy they cannot
relate with human emotion so it enables
them to do more callous things that many
of us would not feel comfortable doing
from an empathetic standpoint and so I
guess that would make them literally
more savage and a psychopath which is a
problem Shane kept comparing saying a
sociopath in a psychopath with the same
playing and implying I don't think he
said it's the same thing but he wasn't
very clean and but like he kept mixing
them up at some point yeah
well he would say sociopaths and then he
would show Psychopaths on the screen and
like someone with a knife so I was
reading about this trying to figure out
what is the difference so actually all
psychopaths are sociopaths but a
psychopath is a more severe version of a
sociopath they tend to be more violent
they tend to be more criminal and they
tend to be more ruthless mm-hmm a
sociopath can still have bonds with like
family members and strong friends but
random people and did they meet on the
street they do not have any empathy for
at all mm-hmm so there is a distinction
but this implication that they're all
you know creepy murderers yeah is not is
not true but at any rate at any rate
that's that then there was a part at the
end of Shane's new I'm checking out on
this on this documentary honestly it's
so long - it's a lot but this part made
me uncomfortable I'm not gonna lie so
here he's teasing this one's called the
enemies of Jake Paul and he is teasing
in the next episode this therapist that
he sat down with is gonna go undercover
as a producer secretly they're not gonna
tell Jake Paul so that she can study him
all day and make a diagnosis of him
it seems kind of unethical I mean I'm so
here dad the whole thing is making me
uncomfortable honestly he Shane does
acknowledge that I mean he knows that
it's weird still gonna do it but anyway
here it is
and she's there too whole time I don't
think he's going to be like themselves I
think he's gonna be comfortable I think
he's going to be kind of a fake so I
came up with a plan it sounds really
shady plan is I'm gonna pretend to be
he's going to be watching like that's
how she makes her diagnosis like she's
this is her all day I just love the
image of this therapist with them all
day like this just looking at the side
of her vision at them anyway it's free
weights tray I don't know man it's just
strange like I mean
what do you think well first of all let
me say this Jake specifically is cool so
there you go I don't know I didn't like
I think it's unnecessary because if you
if she went like Jake would still be
himself over a long day you know if
they're at his house well I guess you'll
put on a show for like five minutes but
eventually he'll be himself a sociopath
apparently is capable and well aware of
the facade that they put on mm-hmm
actually what I read is that a
psychopath so a sociopath generally is
more messy and how they present
themselves to the world but a psychopath
is extremely efficient that they can
have a mask up all the time even under
stress and duress so that they never let
their guard down yeah
so it is one of the attributes but that
being said I really don't think I really
don't think Jake is a sociopath yeah
it's yeah I the thing is he didn't
really need this whole angle I would
have been interested in just one a
really sincere look into Jake Paul's
life like I don't know why the day with
him yeah I don't know that we needed
this really dramatic mm-hmm angle of
sociopathy yeah you know PewDiePie made
a beauty buddy he made some good points
about a really long video but he was
like when they were talking about
sociopathy him and the therapist were
saying that it was like a key--and gross
yeah I guess a I don't know what do I
know but it's getting bizarre ahh mmm
it's a wild ride man this is some wild
new territory here people are loving it
yeah and the thing is it's Jake Paul so
it's hard for anyone to be like it's
very difficult ever take Jake or Logan
sight like Logan made a very reasonable
response to to Shane's video and has
yeah he did like I was I was feeling
kind of bad it like here like they're
down votes is like 130 thousand down and
he didn't really say anything worthy of
a down though personally my
that's the world we live in hmm that's
the tube we tube in so uh I'm not gonna
lie I'm gonna watch it I'm gonna watch
it
it seems unethical but I'm gonna watch
them what else we got
Cavanaugh Cavanaugh this [ __ ] guy
this Cavanaugh guy he's trying to get on
Supreme Court again there's a lot of
politics going on here you guys probably
heard of Cavanaugh and how he was
accused of all this sexual misconduct
which is sexual misconduct that's a nice
way of saying rape kind of but
regardless of what he did or didn't do I
don't know my only interest in this my
friends is the fact that they are
arguing over what is a booth now boo
thing is a big part of this show as you
may recall we have been trying to get to
the bottom of what a booth is for a long
time I feel bad for the right into the
equation a booth and a goof and the gaff
is a laugh what happens if you boof a
goof now we were wondering what's a
booth and Eric from common etiquette
came in with a definition as we were
wondering what is a booth and I look it
up it's not actually word but you found
it on urban dictionary hell yeah the
best which is the perfect place to
define something like this apparently
and correct me if your definition is
wrong it's when you shove drugs up your
ass when you go to a rave or dance party
you booth it in yes we're on the same
page that's act so actually I've got a
revived that definitional that I'm
pretty sure it means taking drugs up the
ass because what I've heard because
apparently the the anus the colon is a
very absorb absorb if absorptive and so
drinking is like you know and it's like
you do an enema we don't it's like this
you know this mean where it's like I
sleep i I'm awake so drinking alcohol in
the mouth I sleep booting alcohol in
your ass I'm awake
refers to flatulence yes so basically
the same anus sucks and as way more
membrane so if you're taking any kind of
illicit drug you put it up the ass Bowl
and you all gonna be get taking that one
great ride ticket to Valhalla if you're
willing to do that you don't have to
taste it you don't have to encounter any
bad so you just boof it right up there
what do you shotgun a beer up your ass I
don't know how that works I heard there
was kids that were dipping vodka or
tampons in vodka and then shoving it up
there I'd get drunk
it's like Jesus drink like a shot it's
drinking but apparently you get drunk
quicker and it's a pleasant experience
but I just I love you know postpones
really good at shotgunning beers and are
fasiqun boo-bear bar man yeah didn't a
friend of the show steve-o in one of
those Jackass movies moved a beer out of
like a beer bong yeah that's what I'd
like to see postponed oh I think that's
the rock star that I just like to
imagine someone on their back with their
cheeks out and a bunch of Bros shoving
that tube up dude's ass vaseline ended
up by Tyra Banks and just boof and a
beer right up the stink hole what was
Tara banks - she's the Vaseline goddess
no was she in your picture she they use
Vaseline from her oh it's the good stuff
if Austin's gonna be buffing any beers
make sure he gets the best Vaseline to
lube that anus up because that's
probably so much easier to prove then
drinking it but at any rate let's watch
let's watch a future Supreme Court
Justice discuss goofing and this is the
greatest time have you how do you
pronounce that refers to flatulence no
it does not refer to flatulence oh we
all know even if you supporting this guy
you know that this guy is not talking
about flatulence so fart farting yeah
when an opinion guys and again I'm not
taking sides I'm not throwing my chips I
don't I'm so over politics okay I'm here
for the boof's and the goose but we all
know all of us watching even those of
you whose
or Cavanaugh and everything he does you
know or whatever what the [ __ ] ever you
know what a booth is and this man did
they ever get to what a goof is they
didn't ask that
wish I was there I'll tell him what is a
goof define a goof it's kind of hard to
define it's a laugh
it's a giggle it's a giggle hey this guy
if he goes down for lying about what a
booth is this country perjury now with
eight America great again I mean he lied
to the Senate I mean right here we all
know what it's perjury of the highest
order we've all everyone here who's a
fan of this podcast and listens here
regular basis in your deposition that
they ask you to define what a meme is
very similar moment meme is kind of hard
to define yeah a booth has a very
literal definition it's not a flatulent
refers to flatulence no it does not but
I'm saying that we've all here who've
been a fan and washed along and learned
along with us we all learned together
what is boo f---ing yeah and this judge
he wants to sit on the highest court in
the world he committed perjury over what
it means to put beer up his ass hmm he
should go down for that I'm saying if
you're actually I've never heard that
yeah it seems like a nice word for
farting yeah he's went to Yale so he's
not allowed to say fart yes it's a
flatulence
but one of you was just like that's when
you put beer up your ass
the I believe you look I was 15 I was 16
years old we were young boys it's a joke
it's what happens it's putting beer up
your ass I think that would get him more
credit with people absolutely that guy's
telling the [ __ ] truth
yeah you wouldn't lie about that I mean
I guess he was trying to be more candid
he kept trying to downplay his drinking
so that's what it was he's always trying
to be like oh nothing and there has
anything to do with drinking
look dude you put some you at you and
you took some beer up the ass I get him
and we're all gonna have fun you were
young man at the time yeah by the way
this guy's name is mr. Whitehouse wonder
what kind of job that guy's after
imagine having a president called mr.
White House President White House this
just in from the White House and
someone's like over John and Papa John's
Papa John Pappajohn at Papa John's Papa
John anyway I just loved that boo thing
has been the center of a national
controversy and I had to acknowledge it
so judge hmm shouldn't lied about the
boo thing
Jabar first a flatulence who does not
absolutely does not everyone listening
you goddamn walnut does not so up next
we've got Ian the intern the wonderful
beloved by all he has got a presentation
Kanye has been all over the news people
have been waiting yeah Kanye's been up
to a lot and you guys may not know this
about he and the intern but them he is a
huge Kanye fan he is aced he's actually
even written a screenplay about Kanye's
like yeah yeah you know that no he's he
is
I mean he's obsessed it's a little weird
so he has come with a presentation and
I'm super excited I mean everything in
put together is gold after that that's
coming up after the break then we got a
Papa John update we got all kinds of fun
stuff including this check this out open
John Oblates are my favorite updates God
every time it's amazing and this times
no exception
a dream cruise on Australia was ruined
by 1300 Indian men partying from a
tobacco company that brought Playboy
Bunnies with them and ruined the boat
ride for everybody we got footage we got
everything you need to enjoy that story
so we're gonna throw it to a commercial
break and when we come back and your boy
is going to be here with all the Kayne
updates that you could ever want
and so much more stay tuned 23andme is a
DNA testing service that can offer
insights into your ancestry health
wellness and traits my dudes I love this
thing man you spit in a cup you send it
off some dude in the office
throws it in his mouth and then he tells
you everything you need to know about
you I'm just kidding I don't think
that's how they do it but you do spit in
a vial you send it off to a bunch of
scientists they crunch the numbers and
they tell you all this interesting stuff
about you like your weight your sleep
quality caffeine intake sense of taste
whether you are likely to be lactose
intolerant and so much and if you're
likely to die from Alzheimer's or not
which is a really fun one but it's been
done it's good to know and it's easy to
do the bitter taste report here's some
interesting ones do you prefer sweet or
salty foods DNA can play a role in
determining your food preferences and
that's interesting sleep report are you
a deep sleeper are you a light sleeper
are you likely to move during your sleep
it's all in that vial of spit folks
saturated fat weight report based on
your genetics may are you likely to be a
big fat fatty from that fat or like Elon
Escape we have different dimensions and
frankly it's not it's not your fault
remember that scene from Good Will
Hunting that's me that's one two three
and meets with their hand on my shoulder
going Ethan it's not your phone it's not
your fault lactose intolerant
hey they got it all and so much more
they can tell you about what your
background is from your geographical
background yeah Italian you're French
what are you let's find out alien I
Italian let's find out right now head on
over at 23andme this is interesting
fascinating stuff you're gonna learn all
about yourself it's so awesome go to
23andme dot-com / h3 that's two three
the numbers two three and me.com / h3
imaginal world where on your phone you
can order anything you want at any time
of the day any day of the year
that's what posts mates gives you that's
the power of post mates I love posts
mates I love posts mix it's the best
thing that's ever been invented here's
how it works you just download the Hat
24 hours a day 365 year postman's will
bring you whatever you want within that
hour you can even see where your food is
and track your driver to make sure
there's no effing funny be business like
a personal assistant
it's basically yeah a freelance personal
assistants that's right you look very
good analogy
you forgot eggs you forgot milk no effin
problem craving a tasty burger check
looking for some beer some cigarettes
you know what I mean okay that's just
it's nice when you're like man I'm I'm
drunk and I'm at home I want a frozen
pizza and some cigarettes
that's what post mates is all about oh
oh I want some front on this food app
but my favorite restaurant doesn't
deliver polish mates does every time all
right
post mates is your new long-term
munchies booty call they wrote that not
me I just want to make that clear but
it's a good point that's a good analogy
you do not get to [ __ ] your driver
though that is not part of the deal so
for a limited time post mates is giving
you $100 of free delivery credit for
your first 7 days so to start your free
deliveries download the app today and
use code h3 that's code h3 for $100 a
free delivery credit for your first 7
days save the hassle get the food you
love fast at boats mates with code h3
listen sometimes we can all use a little
help and some people more than others
okay here's what's the deal sexual
performance issues it's more common than
you think
over 25% of new EDD cases are guys under
the age of 40 and 40% of men by age 40
struggle with not being able to get
their dick rock-hard like they used to
be able to get it and even the world's
greatest actors can't fake one that's
right even Tom Cruise can't fake having
an erection I don't know what Tim he's
not the best actor the Marlin who's the
best actor in the world he can't fake an
erection why do you guys Leo DiCaprio
he doesn't help get an erection I got
rock thrown rock hard why do guys turn
to weird solutions or do nothing when
they can turn to medicine and science my
dudes this is the real deal we've got
well known generic equivalents to name
repre scription to help you combat and
fight this erectile disfunction epidemic
we as men need our dicks rock-hard and
ready to [ __ ] okay these are
prescriptions back to by science there's
no waiting room there's no awkward
in-person doctor visit old wines
you're saving ours by going to four hems
dot-com slush h-3 it's so easy
sorry it's h3 IDI it's so easy answer a
few quick questions and chat with the
doctor for confidential review products
are shipped directly to your door severe
IDI isn't just an issue for rich old
guys in bathtubs why are they in bathtub
it affects men's in their 30s and their
40s doing whatever you do I don't I
don't take a bath I'm no I haven't taken
a bath since I was 5 being your best
means performing your best it's a wreck
tile without the dysfunction folks made
hard say stay hard say hello to your
little friend by going to trip by going
to 4 hems fo r hims comm /h 3 EB and
today you can try a month supply for
just $5 will get you started for just 5
bucks while supplies last so see the
website for all details this will
usually cost you hundreds of bucks a
doctor of pharmacy that's for hims comm
/h 3 Edie
get your dick rock [ __ ] argh welcome
back everybody
[Music]
we're here within the intern who has
prepared with us another of his classic
PowerPoint presentations thank you so
much again for taking the time put that
together first how are you I'm doing
good
I've been working on this a long long
day it's your life at work it's the
culmination of your life's work the
culmination of the full 24 hours for
sure are you are a kanye mega fan is
that correct to say yeah I'd probably
say top 100 top one on your fans in the
world I'd say so
that's so you know anyone disputes that
you try try me so the only way you could
be a bigger fan is kind of by stalking
him and waiting on to his house and
attempting to murder and wearing his
skin yeah so you're you're just one step
under us a psychopathic murderer yeah
excellent good now whatever is
sociopaths
I don't we shouldn't get anything yeah
now it's not the time or place it was a
therapist fine now tell me what is it
about Kayne that intrigued do you well
let me say are you fans of anyone else
or Kanye like he's your guy
there's a lot of people I like but he's
definitely he's your guy yeah and what
is it about Kayne that that you love so
much that I choose you
he's probably the only person in pop
culture that I'd get close to saying
like role model he's a role model
whatever were the attributes that you
look up to of his like how is Blaine
honesty the gets him in a lot of trouble
but he feels like one of the only
authentic evil and like everything he
thinks even though you know some of it
is stupid mm-hmm he doesn't hesitate to
let you know all of his flaws or all of
his issues and that's more relatable to
me than everyone else he's authentic
yeah
yeah definitely and we see all the
faults and the cracks and all that
interest and it's it's like you know
everyone's like that but he's like one
of the few races or even enough to be
like yeah this is this is how I am and
I'm kind of you know and you're a fan of
his music obviously yeah yeah no he's
great
he's your favorite musician as well as
artists yeah yeah have you seen his sex
day
wait he never made it on video oh did
you have you seen on using immigrations
sex tape yeah yeah what do you think
about it any good it's not good it's not
that good all these celebrity sex tapes
are so underrated it's like do you think
that she intentionally released that
right it's like not quite sure but it's
true that that sex tape was kind of what
put her on the map right it definitely
helped before that and then she was
really close with Paris Hilton in those
circles instead I think I saw on pornhub
that the Kim Kardashian sex tape has
like over a hundred million views crazy
yeah no it's like massive on there it's
pretty wild
okay you've seen it yeah I mean okay
yeah I mean you're not missing much it's
just it's a lot of like dude POV right
yeah it's just it's bad bad angles you
just can really enjoy the show as they
say how many times have you watched it
more than often just like them every
once in a while
no not even recently I'd like multiple
times well now I respect Kim in the fan
you don't watch it anymore no but before
how many times have you seen it more
than five times or less than five times
less be honest honestly I'd say less III
would tell you truth like with like
three three four yeah well obviously
halves I mean you have to be crazy to
watch the whole thing and are you a fan
of Kim Kardashian as much as yeah not as
nowhere near but I've come to like her
through Kanye do you see what he finds
in her like the yeah what is well that's
another both of these people are so
hated like like vitriolic like Yuri
right and I think it's it's you know a
little unnecessary she's like everything
she just did getting that woman out of
prison that was very cool and she's
actively it's weird there's pictures of
her just she's going to the White House
now kind of semi-regular hanging out and
trying to she has a whole lid I was
trying to [ __ ] her
oh yeah let's get started into the what
is then what is this Kanye what verse
the world what are we calling this uh
Kanye decoded Kanye decoded Wow
yeah well my hand hey man go right in
so Jobs Ford Edison ok Disney I see
where this is goin Stein Picasso how
many of these how many please please I'm
in the middle of something here
Shakespeare and they were Warhol thank
you I forgot for a second von schweetz
Dora the Explorer von schweetz
apparently
vanellope von rodriguez song start here
in da Vinci
you know Hughes Phelps did you rehearse
this Socrates I'm getting to a thing
Tesla you know Michelangelo there oh my
god
Hawking are you trolling me is their
presentation or is it just we're getting
there getting there
Beethoven Jackson mm-hmm buddy the elf
not not Will Ferrell they know but he's
West are you with me so far
I think so what is it you're trying to
say and great mind these are all people
Kanye's compared himself to Wow okay so
you definitely you had a thing here yeah
there's this reason behind the madness
okay so ya know the elf what did you
what's who was that a Disney yeah oh
von schweetz yeah why did he compare
self the von schweetz
he said cuz if you've seen record Ralph
yes she like is that she's The Glitch
mm-hmm Kanye says I'm the ghoulish
village we're gonna decode that right
yeah and you know that is what we're
trying to do for the matrix Kanye
decoded didn't
political affiliation mm-hmm a lot of
people are upset about you know this
guy's recent activities absolutely ow
it kind of kicked off a few weeks ago he
announced his new album yandi mm he said
it was coming out September 29th yandi
is Kanye and Gandhi oh that's not a bold
claim and here's the album cover it's
similar to his album from 2013 yeezus so
this is the yeah he's making a play on
words that he's some kind of Savior but
this he actually believed that because
he is has manic states does he believe
he is uses probably in those states he's
gets close especially recently he's on
this whole love thing I'm talking about
but so he releases this September 29th
and then I gave it a little spin they're
very nice
SNL announced that he would be the host
on the 29th or he'd be the musical guest
so everyone assumed okay he's gonna come
play some new songs the album will come
out so first song I'm sure you saw this
performance again I love it yeah it's
catchy little Park in my head
song one we're having fun yeah we're
having fun out here
song 2 so cool so cool are those your
summaries oh yeah that's my review you
know came out played a song called we
got love it's great or equal song three
liberals can't control me hmm
takes a turn hold on takes a turn and
hang on people weren't quite happy about
it he launched into a speech at the end
of he was playing ghost town and then
NBC cut the stream Wow
they cut him off yeah I haven't seen
this and some some people are saying oh
it was just because they ran out of time
but it was right before he launched in
this speech and someone recorded it who
was back stable they cut it it never got
aired yeah
[Music]
here's a recording from one of his main
producers who was backstage see the cast
laughing in the background
control program thank you thanks fellas
s yeah he was off there he's killing it
no that can't be true yeah la New York
writers rappers musicians so it's easy
to make it seem like it's so so so
one-sided
and they're just stuck up there yeah
they've never held it held them hostage
a little bit also they're very
anti-trump so it's kind of bitching them
out too yeah
[Applause]
you know what I thought that was a
beautiful authentic tender moment and
it's a real goddamn shame they cut him
off like that it kind of gives you
context to why he's wearing this hat
right kind of feel like they should have
capped it in it or not really I mean it
is obviously very provocative but I
understand I appreciate the point he's
trying to make of like stepping across
the aisle and seeing people as people
and not because it's so easy from the
left to right to just demonize and
that's what they do because I was a lot
of left-wing media like Jimmy Kimmel and
the Stephen Colbert's and all these guys
and they're just they talk about and
Bill Maher they talk about the other
side like they're just monsters you know
Bill Maher is the only one that actually
will have a conversation with that aside
yes but like Jimmy Kimmel treats them
like they're monsters
yeah so I appreciate the sentiment yeah
and there was another part I don't know
where it went but where he said like you
guys kind of go at Trump like a little
too hard and it's nonstop and it doesn't
really help anything
yeah so he told him as well like I love
how he's like thank you for a platform
and they're like dude we pulled the plug
yeah they're like we gotta get this guy
out here man I feel bad yeah well I'm
glad that somebody recorded it yeah all
right I have a pail of people reacted to
that clip not great not great no there's
another one that everyone saw first
Chris Rock was in the audience and he
was filming it and he's just laughing
and my Chris Rock filmed it what a weird
twist yeah on his Instagram story and
you could hear him chuckling and being
like oh my god
well what do you expect this Kanye West
yeah you know that's it's weird that he
would have they're surprised yeah but
also I find it I find it a little bit
rude and condescending to laugh at a guy
who's trying to express himself
authentically yeah it's like listen to
the guy you know what I'm saying that's
kind of the point that he's making
because just because he's wearing that
hat he's immediately labeled like a joke
and it's like why can't anyone work like
50% of the country apparently supports
Donald Trump and rocks that hat so why
is it like that when you
that hat it's like wearing a swastika or
some [ __ ] it's like that's the those
your neighbors yeah the Hat is it's
getting such like a visceral immediate
response from people and then they don't
want to dig deeper but again I'm sure
there's I feel like I'm maybe supporting
that too much because then there's a lot
of people like well he said I'm not
saying one were the other I appreciate
the act of trying to reconcile these
very fractured country that we live in I
mean I had that immediate reaction when
I saw him with the Hat on the show I was
like oh yeah that was my first view but
it's all just like oh we're all so sick
of politics too it's like just [ __ ]
make music and entertain us cuz there's
also people that are like oh well he's
only doing that because he doesn't
really care he's just he's in the
headlines again and I don't believe that
yeah because he kept doing after his
last album case by having a lot of [ __ ]
for it yeah so the day after that then
he posts his photo
that's the two-five Instagram and the
caption this represents good in America
becoming whole again we will no longer
outsourced to other countries we build
factories here in America and create
jobs
we'll provide jobs for all who are free
from prisons as we abolish the
Thirteenth Amendment message sent with
love I'm not sure the Trump said
anything about peace and luring people
from prison yeah he's and then this got
him in some trouble cuz yeah this this
is this is less about this is more
political this is like I'm a I support
Donald Trump yeah and then he said
abolish the Thirteenth Amendment which
is the one that you know ended slavery
but then there's like a section of that
that says except for prisons yeah and he
later said I meant the word amended it's
like bro you gotta you gotta refine like
you got it no that doesn't come off good
yeah with them with a mag ahead yeah and
I think he's still trying to be like
this a lot of people pointed out that
like the Magna hat has a label that says
made in China and so it's like if you
want to start their movement
well you know there's this great clip of
when Donald was running for the
Republican nominee yeah he went on Jimmy
Kimmel it was so great and Kimmel had a
bunch of Trump ties and there was a
label made in China you know yeah so
then the response to this here's a
couple realities Evans captured American
games
Captain America done with a lot of life
he jumped in 600,000 like yeah so his
response there's nothing more maddening
than debating someone who doesn't know
history doesn't read books and frames
her myopia as virtue the level of
unapologetic conjecture I've encountered
lately isn't just frustrating it's retro
aggressive unprecedented and absolutely
terrifying that got 600,000 likes I
don't think people even understood I
don't like he got away too hard to sound
smart there yeah he went all-in he he
got the Webster's out he fight yeah that
was straight-up sponsored by
thesaurus.com seriously 600,000 people
slammed that I mean that's just such I
mean I yeah and then Lana Del Rey
commented this one had like I was right
under his photo this one I'm like 30,000
won by the way I want to say it once
again for the record not I'm not
supporting in favor of Donald Trump and
in fact I want to say he definitely made
it too political at that point yeah yeah
yeah I didn't like that one he cuz then
again it's like oh we're talking about
bringing it's like a I like I like a
gesture of healing the divide yeah but
then he made a political and using these
talking points and I so I understand the
backlash at that point should have kept
a pure about here just you gotta stick
the why yeah I like it where he's like
don't scapegoat me just because I like
this guy along with 50% of the America
but now you got Chris Evans going at the
source calm and writing a dissertation a
thesis a doctor all on it dr. America
okay I cannot believe 600,000 people
pretended to understand what he just
drove I can't you can't understand
no I can believe that they there's
nothing more maddening than debating
someone who doesn't know history doesn't
read books and frames their myopia as
virtue what the level unapologetic
conjecture what the [ __ ] just say what
you mean you do why you writing an essay
on Twitter the level of unapologetic and
gesture of a Canon lady isn't just
frustrating its retrogressive
unprecedented and absolute specially
when you're gonna like criticize it kind
of for not being educated then you come
up with the I can't be worried I dare
you to what about the dictionary indeed
without this we'd such a pompous fight
like just [ __ ] say what you want to
say dude you don't like what the guy
says you think he's uneducated and you
know yeah he definitely went a little
overboard and then Lana Del Rey Trump
becoming our president was a loss for
the country but your support of him is a
loss for the culture mm-hmm I can only
assume you relate to his personality on
some level delusions of grandeur extreme
issues with narcissism none of which
would be a talking point if we weren't
speaking about the man leading our
country if you think it's alright to
support someone who believes it's okay
to grab a woman by the [ __ ] just
because he's famous then you need an
intervention as much as he does
something so many narcissists will never
get because there just isn't enough help
for the issue message sent with concern
that will never be addressed mm-hmm so
at a real beef that's beef she performed
at his wedding
well oh so tell me how do you feel about
about what Kanye said as a fan and a
student of his I think that I think that
he's going about it the completely wrong
way right and I see what he's trying to
do
and I'm not gonna get like I think
people aren't shocked because I was
looking up like what celebrities
actually endorsed Trump and it's a real
row of characters he's like far in a way
the most relevant entertainer to
everyone Raj meatloaf and [ __ ] like that
yeah like meatloaf the first
one was roseanne that was the first one
that popped up no fair anyone saying
yeah and like whole Cogan you know so
yeah I think people can't believe that
because no one else is even getting
close to that conversation who is
popular in rag yeah so and then the last
one was from Questlove he said you know
we aren't even typing his name I find it
strange he's a trend and yet we are all
typing the same thing for all that he's
cancelled talk there was an ounce of
hope in our souls tonight but all we got
was well I'm kind of sad man that was
about the SNL performance so all three
of those guys jumped in and then snoop
snoop snoop one in for the kill this guy
named DJ Pugh reposted the photo and
said Magga music ain't getting attention
so he's saying he's kind of promo
sure and then snoop in the comments make
your music again believe N word oh yeah
thank you music great again yeah N word
yeah with the a at the end and then he
called him Uncle Tom now Uncle Tom for
those of you don't know who's Hilda no
yes there was a book I don't remember
what it was called right but a fictional
characters called Uncle Tom's Cabin
oh yeah Uncle Tom's Cabin a black man
that owned slaves
so he's betraying his own kind and other
words yeah so he said that and here was
a earlier post from him what the [ __ ]
this was from when Kanye first put the
hat on
he said the new Kanye well all white now
way to go dude edited him you know so
he's been mad at Connie for a while yeah
after this one on the left then Kanye
went out and wore a picture of Snoop
Dogg on his shirt and then immediately
Snoop Dogg posted it and said
forgiveness is everything so he won him
over and then like and then I love how
the goop was like you Uncle Tom which is
kind of like the worst thing you could
say to a another block I mean that's
that sounds
lotta hatin all right and then he just
wears the shirt while still having them
I had yeah but I but again it's a it's
great that's what he's you know he's
trying to do but I think Kanye
beautifully disarmed that situation yeah
and it worked yeah work but I was like
so who's forgiving who in that scenario
you know what I mean
snoop I guess it was forgiving Kanye
because he were the first he
acknowledged him because that's you know
I'm going to use that move I wrong I'm
going to start wearing this shirt and
then Trump tweeted after the SNL
performance like many you have a Trump
you had one last week the try like man
no like I can do my best as Stephen
Colbert doing Trump that's nobody wants
that like many I don't watch Saturday
Night Live of a Trump no not a good like
man I mean it's all I don't like many I
don't watch Saturday Night Live even
though I passed hosted it no longer
funny no talent or charm it is just a
political ad for the Dems word is that
Kanye West who put on a maggot have to
the show despite being told no was great
he's leading the charge
very cool Kanye and very cool so
everyone's kind of going but why why is
he doing this why is he just you know
tanking his legacy like this no no I
can't
it's a good so you gotta go back to 2013
this isn't the first time he's done this
a lot of people kind of forgot he put
out his album yeezus
in June of 2013 and then he put out all
of the merch and all of the merch was
covered in the Confederate flag wow
that's pretty racy yeah literally and so
that was a huge thing at the time then I
didn't see that yeah everything we were
following Cayenne so close
Oh kind of like until we met either I'm
not supposed to be [ __ ] I guess ain't
you yeah so a bunch of the merch had a
lot of people were upset and here's a
clip of him in 2013 explaining why he
wore why he wore the Confederate flag
merch the tour Mirchi I read which I
thought was kind of like but people I
feel like people just want to find
something to get yeah you know I just
want to get all riled up about something
but it was about the tour merch and the
Confederate flags and the skeleton
imagery and things like that and do you
think people are overreacting with this
react how you want like I said it's
making them reacting yes sir energy you
got his good energy you know the
Confederate flag represented slavery in
a way the way my my shot I'm that's why
I strike take on what I know about it
right so I made the song new slaves so I
took the Confederate flag and made it my
flat
it's my flag now now go do I like yeah
that's great that's a great that's
beautiful I love that yeah and then just
this was the day before the SML
performance where he was explaining the
maggot hat so that's what he said yeah
but he [ __ ] it up when he started
talking about political points yeah
that's definitely where it's getting
muddled that up yeah I think he started
with this idea and then a bunch of sort
of right you know right-leaning people
in media started reaching out to him and
he started taking meetings with them and
I think then they got in as me Brian he
got some polluted
yeah he got some talking points from
them and yeah
you know see there you go he's becoming
what he hates kind of isn't it true I
think that he really I don't think
there's any maliciousness no I know but
he's becoming but he's almost a pawn to
the well whatever what the [ __ ] do I
know no it's kind of like you know right
I'm people whispering in his ear and
he's coming out yeah mm-hmm talking
about
you know bringing jobs back or whatever
not that that's a bad thing but it is a
talking point yeah and then let's see so
that was from that thing he's wearing a
make America great again hat and then
his sweatshirt is Colin Kaepernick he
keeps trying to do this duality thing
god these are all the people he follows
on Twitter
it's like Bernie Sanders Trump you know
MA and then he followed those two at the
same exact time Bernie and Trump and
then he followed Candace Owens who is a
Republican media personality and Emma
Gonzalez who is kind of she was leading
that anti gray he followed them at the
exact same time to exact same time like
yeah it's like a median so he's trying
to create he's making everything a
statement yeah
only eight followers yeah it's an
exclusive club interesting some day
wouldn't you get I in that Club yeah
who is your opposite match yeah fine an
emesis for you here's a tweet I haven't
done enough research on conservatives to
call myself or be called one I'm just
refusing to be enslaved by monolithic
thought alright here's a it's more of
just him saying you know the Hat it's
not about policies I'm not a politician
like that it represents overcoming fear
and doing what you felt no matter what
anyone said you can't bully me liberals
can't bully me news can't bully me the
hip-hop community can't believe me and
here's Kim saying you know we would talk
about policies and he doesn't agree with
the policies he likes his personality
and how he made it to be president when
everyone really underestimated him all
right
he likes the dragon energy yeah and
here's one of his good friends after the
after the performance he has never said
he agrees with Trump's policies just the
fact that no one would have thought
Trump would be president meaning he did
the unbelievable and that's the
connection only him wearing the Hat is
his choice and he feels he's stripping
the power of hate that people give that
hat by wearing it he wants to love all
no matter how they speak of him or
whatever we don't agree with because
that's how God works God loves
if he was trying to strip the power of
hate that people give it by wearing it
he would he's never said that no not
well he said he put like positive energy
into the Hat but what is that means it's
like diamond water they run in but he's
like what when asked about the energy
yeah he's right he washed it during
water when asked about the Confederate
flag he gave a very straightforward
exclamation he said this is represents
slavery and now it's mine yeah okay well
yeah okay god bless God loves all and
then here's a quick clip he was asked
about if he liked why he is showing
support for Trump oh wait where to go
there we go so maybe I think you like
the idea yeah not necessarily
I do Donald Trump with the idea of an
outside of infiltrating yeah I like that
it showed you that anything is possible
shows you that it doesn't even like
Virgil working at Louis Vuitton Trump
being an office it's a time for the
unconventional I'm very not a
traditional think I'm I'm a
nonconformist you know so that relates
to the nonconformist part of me now you
know but I'm also I'm a producer I like
the segue things I like to take ODIs
chop it up do it like this one so what's
the a version the a version to be the
Trump campaign and maybe the Bernie
Sanders principles that would be my mix
and stuff but I think both had you know
you know I need it so that's there you
go so I don't know where he is with his
thoughts on politics okay
why are you though so really the
question was like you know can you turn
this into something positive
sure I don't personally I don't think so
mm-hmm
and you guys who charged like the yeah
you can't in a way like it's hard to
just say I just like Trump because he
made it against all odds mm-hmm
without acknowledging everything that he
stands for mm-hmm well I also remember
call him saying that he has he
redesigned the hat yeah he has a Yeezy
version of the make America great again
had that he wears and I think that's
fantastic that he made his own hat there
yeah he changed the brim changed the
thing it doesn't look better I have to
say it looks he looks a little goofy
when he I had fit like if you recall the
picture on Instagram that's like a total
goof angle yeah well at any rate Kanye
he's out there he's doing his thing he's
authentic in you as a fan you love him
against all odds forever so what what if
you could say anything to Kanye right
now what would you tell him Kanye is
right here what he said I'd probably say
well first I think that I appreciate
what he's trying to do yes but it's like
it's like a Sisyphus task
he's like rolling a boulder Chris Evans
yeah the source out it's like and I saw
some people going well like oh like the
swastika used to be a symbol of peace
and then they changed it to make it a
different thing but it's not it once
that happens you can't bring it back
can't take the Hitler mustache yeah
I said it's like it's easier to to
poison the well than to like purify the
water that's my thinking interest if he
wants to use the Hat I think he has to
design redesign it a little further yeah
I agree
talking points what he was saying he's
trying to remix yeah this ideas but it
didn't change the head enough to fit my
pitch I've got a pitch this isn't the
redesigned one but you've got you know
the Democrats are typically blue
publicans are red the Trump has very red
blue and red combined purple there it is
purple make America great again that's a
brilliant idea and change it to purple
you got good ideas just a plain hat
what's the goal with me
America great again right well then you
change the slogan as well I looked it up
I went to the meanings of colors and I
was that's I was violet the color of
spirituality the energy of red with the
calm ooh divine who decides what color
means a lot of these are marketing
companies as color plays very heavily
okay this is like got it a color that
inspires reflection and self-awareness
it is the color of the sensitive
compassionate intuitive soul violet has
long been associated with royalty and
characteristics of quality and luxury
mom now if you go back to his album
cover the sticker on it was violet yes
do you think he's on to this already
no but I'm trying to do that Kanye I
think you got to keep the make America
great again
because then you have both colors the
same meaning if you go away from the
phrase to become something to different
combine them Kanye who is listening for
sure listen to him he's got great advice
I think or the slogan I think you could
slight I mean it could go both ways but
I think the color would be a good change
maybe make America great mmm cuz it
wasn't not again
not everyone it wasn't great for all
people at any point yeah I'm Kanye he
has this whole thing he's always talking
about oh we teach history class why
don't we teach future class that's this
whole thing so look look forward that's
make it great make America great
stop looking bad now will.i.am that's
Cayenne yeah I'm maybe both that's a
diss took a little form in make America
unified yeah combination okay or make
American love okay that's a little corny
in well I wanted to he's all the people
out there I like the great without each
closes dream
Thank You merica great I do like that
one I think so change the color change
to change the brim on that everybody
tweet to Kanye let him know I think we
got ideas here if he did that then maybe
you and do you think that if Kanye
adopted your idea
from the show would they give you back
memberships here at the Kanye forum that
you were banned from didn't you already
get it back well no I don't think he did
or did he every band I'm back but they
don't know I'm there oh you have a new
account but they couldn't know who's
right and there they're on to me i eyes
a weird game here over someone commented
the other day and they were like you the
way you type makes it seem like you've
been here a lot longer than your
registration date they all know each
other huh yeah community how many people
how many active members is that
community yet well there's there's like
like 10,000 people on there but then
there's really heavy people and you're
heavy
yeah how many hours a day are you on
that well not as much now because if I
use it at home
they'll trace my IP I'm in deep you know
i the Hat should say unban e'en from the
forum that's funny
we got a you end well thank you for
decoding Kayne rest in peace to Mac
Miller I see you're reppin that there on
your hoody yes and Ian thanks so much
for your presentation we wish all the
best you can leave out thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much all right so there
you guys have it the Kanye West decoded
mm-hmm what do you take away from that
ela do you think what do you think Ian
is always making me like see the good in
content that maybe I didn't see before
mm-hmm yeah well in he's a good kid he's
got a strong head on his shoulders so
III generally he's got good ideas so
when he says that Kanye is his favorite
person in the world I listen right and
all right what's going on there I
actually started listening to his new
album because of ya means adore Serena I
gotta say there's a lot of the great
Katya one yeah there's a lot of good
stuff there so let's make America love
again and it's it's stuff too I like I
said when I saw him with the head I was
like what yeah like why but when you
look more into it I see what he's trying
to do I see
god bless him god bless it all right
well let's get into speaking of uh
conservatives Papa John is a prominent
conservative did you know that and he is
currently under a huge criminal
conspiracy by the Clintons and George
Soros to remove him from his pizza
empire Papa John has showed up to court
today I think you just gotta close that
window there on the top right okay Papa
John showed up in court today to testify
in his lawsuit Papa John V Papa John and
he gave testimony he asked for documents
there's a lot of big updates I'd like to
share with you guys Johnny's suing Papa
John's yeah as a story a video here here
we go
mr. Schneider is set to begin testify
not as you mention
no it's matter Pappajohn Shatner is way
funnier ya Schnatter founder former CEO
and former chairman of the board is
seeking documents related to his ouster
as chairman earlier in the summer mr.
Schneider said he's feeling good this
morning ahead of his testimony here's
what else he had to say to us what's
your message to shareholders guys
remember the pop is in the house where
he had the LAV on yeah and he didn't
know that you could hear me was gone
[Music]
[Laughter]
same message we have for 34 years you
know we always acted in their best
interest what's your end goal here do
you want a better interest better pizza
better and greedy Papa John's always in
their best interest
the quality is low because of this
virtual desktop I think okay yeah
although it should be yours not mine
well we'll figure out later return to
the company in a leadership position I
am part of the company did you what's
the cut name of the company what's name
of the company Papa John's and who's the
Papa Steve no suing the company and
Steve he was gonna fire Steve did you
know Steven now he's the CEO it's a
drama is so good I'm telling you they
should rename the company to Papa
Steve's Avon pizza boxes no one's gonna
buy that Steve my faithful employee one
day I'm gonna plan to fire you Stevie I
was going to let you go we were going to
mark ways and now you've taken
everything from me Stevie
you've taken the mirror in her you've
taken two fresh 100% muscle and you've
taken it all and now you changing the
name it's a bummer Stevie all I want is
better pizza better ingredients
and now Stevie my faithful garlic you
come to me and you say yo you broke my
heart Stevie never go against the family
and now I sit in court next to you
Stevie my darling my friend and you said
you look me in the eyes and you say this
pizza empire that I built with my hands
you take the mozzarella and marinara i
kneaded the dough with my own hands
Steve you and you sit across from me in
court today and you say Papa Stevie's
[Music]
all I want for Papa John's is for the
shareholders to make money better better
pizza
and how my son Bo he's a slow boy my boy
my son Bo he doesn't have much prospects
he's got no prospects TV you think his
pizza and buy listen to this this is a
real Godfather tale better interests
better pizza I am part of Papa here's
part two you can go ahead and I feel
like the music companies the old thing
this is all a huge betrayal yeah here we
go hit me with it
well you [ __ ] lag out his team exit
from the courthouse this is one of two
lawsuits that he's filed against the
here he is just coming out right John
different categories of documents that
are related to his ouster as chairman of
the board today he really appeared calm
and reserved that's in stark contrast to
public comments that he's made and also
famous he's put out on his website safe
papajohns.com feels the company didn't
properly protect him as founder after a
Forbes report filled that he'd used a
racial slur the kind characterize what
actually happened mr. Schneider today
also spoke of an intuition a sixth sense
a sense that something may have been
going on with documents that go back to
October 31st I think that works in
intuition he hasn't know if the board's
actions amount to a coup a conspiracy or
perhaps they are
a conspiracy really what happened here I
also spoke to a source close to the
company that said that John seemed a bit
confused today about what documents he
was asking before that troubling because
he is a juror I just want the I just
want the recipe and now Josh and now I
must sue Stevie former colleague and
best friend my advisor I can't see Irish
how do you follow that the advisor
[Music]
I asked to return the recipe and my
after that trade market cheese recipe a
Papa John's the mozzarella it's the it's
designed to melt it's designed to build
evenly over the pizza that's that's a
good of a pipe out of the bead supply I
know it was your Stevie you break you
breaking my heart
and now Stevie I have to take you on a
lake and execute
listen to this [ __ ] said he requests 17
different documents including the recipe
of his marinara sauce as a joke but 17
documents is real the pizza senses were
sensing a pizza conspiracy a coup or
conspiracy Papa speculated that foreign
agents may be acting covertly to
overthrow his pizza empire possibly
speculating that it was little seizures
or possibly Domino's no man I did write
this by the way I spent on this one
write shares
Domon host yes ela thank you very much
for acknowledging that only a great mind
such as mind could such an original joke
shares of the company have fallen more
than 31 percent over the last year but
the company zwo started long before Papa
John was locked in a bitter battle since
hitting an all-time high of 90 cents per
share in December of 2016 Papa John's
stock has lost nearly half of its value
on disappointing same-store sales growth
on Monday the stock was down more than
2% last changing hands at around $50 a
share so they they're already going down
this supports his pizza conspiracy that
the company was not doing well and they
wanted him off because he was check out
what I pulled up ela pulled up something
he said he planned to fire currency Oh
Steve Ritchie who knew his performance
evaluation would be subpar Wow
and now Stevie is the new Papa this on
the night of December 26 there will be a
change events the seed of formerly known
as Papa rich Stevie Ritchie but no
longer control the Eastside
the Shatner family is moving in on the
east side we are going to control the
marinara supply the mozzarella supplying
and the black the tomato supply these
boys the Ricci family they know good I'm
trustworthy then their performances Sub
Pop and so it is my well as grand papa
as the god papa that the CEO Richie
shall be Roma and so on this day of
December 26 Bubba Richie I guess I give
him a kiss mwah
it's the kiss of faith and this time
wanted mozzarella this award-winning
marinara sauce to which I give to you my
son Bo the the award-winning cross today
it's a pizza wall we're going to wall
here's a twist here's a big twist within
the proceedings he was asked whether he
had some settlements with some women
Shatner stated that he has
confidentially agreements with at least
two women but didn't specify what those
men he the woman twenty four euros all
the time sued shatter shatter shatter
the SH big snotty boy Papa in 1999
alleging that he'd sexually harassed her
for months
repeatedly visiting her house and
kissing her and groping her according to
court filings Shatner has denied the
allegations and as they say Papa is and
will ever for be in the house so it's an
interesting twist of fate for Papa
because he went to seek documents to try
to prove there was a pizza conspiracy
but what he did is he unsealed other
documents about him being in the house
with a an employee that he allegedly
kiss
and groped papa has denied the
allegations do you think the Papa do you
think he uses a loop when he has six or
marinara sauce probably the bottle you
think he's the father thought of sauce
yeah he probably does doesn't he oh my
god oh right Marlon Brando's yeah the
Godfather the guy that played The
Godfather was famously in a butter scene
where he used butter to lube up his [ __ ]
to rape a girl in a movie in a movie so
there you have that
everything connects folks it's a small
world after all I'm gonna papa's house
as they say so that's it that's that you
know what else we got we got Facebook
leak oh good scam yeah get the [ __ ]
Facebook sucks
what's what's Mark Zuckerberg ur smokin
meets suck is a potential sociopath that
guy acts like a computer emulating yeah
I'm not a therapist though I'm just a my
idiot everyone becomes a sociopath
cuz you're wielding trust faith like a
doctor they I don't know if the
therapists take OHS but doctors take
oaths serious stuff you know here so
this this story cracks me up this is
amazing amazing stuff dream cruise
nightmare 1300 Indians partying from a
tobacco company went on a cruise with
3,000 other
I mean 3,000 people in total so half
from these Indian company and half was
Australian people or just not
justification and these guys just took
over this cruise ship
they brought Playboy Playmates they
brought music they brought their own
food and they just completely terrorized
this cruise and everyone
was trapped on this cruise and it was so
bad that Royal Caribbean's had their
refund everybody but there's just
hilarious footage of of all this and it
was like a 24-hour nightmare and this
Australian station made this really
hilarious like scoop very serious they
were very serious about it mm-hmm you
know which I I just was loving this
whole thing cruise ruined by 1300 men on
a work bender here we go
it was supposed to be the cruise of a
lifetime but these excited Aussie
families
what for that feeling when they realized
they were sharing the ship with 1300 men
on a work bender a work bender look at
this chair they turned this [ __ ]
family cruise into like they set up like
a strip club they believe this [ __ ]
these guys are the best and they're all
just out there with their phones out and
[ __ ] like god I love it I love it that a
company was able to just ruin a whole
cruise babe are like traumatized they
said yeah they're ranley like they kept
their doors open
yeah and you just walk by not knowing
where you're gonna see yeah some [ __ ]
naked indian dude there's nothing no
love it
[Music]
they're in the pool they're dominating
everything box not pretty much they were
just people everywhere we get our sail
away party and it was taken over by them
that was the beginning of the end
disappointed I'm sure these other
colorful words overuse wind truck loving
God poor beggars dance teacher wife Cass
and their daughter Talia boarded the
Ravel of how they focus on a story of
life they were all looking forward to
their best crews yet every day was
getting closer was just the heartbeats
pumping out there isn't you're not going
crazy but I know it's just don't go on a
cruise I mean guys cruising is like the
ocean version of ziplining
it probably has zip lines on that cruise
zip lines are so stupid and I've never
been on a cruise I think thought about
it have been ones it's awful right yeah
and every time I hear someone was on a
cruise it sounds so bad and the worst
part about is that you're in the middle
you cannot [ __ ] escape that boat I
had a friend who went recently and you
have this cluster phobic tiny room hmm
so you can't even like go to your room
to everyone go to your rooms tiny and
don't even get me started on rogue waves
what's that I'd like you to start don't
even get me started
rogue waves dude are anomalies on the
ocean okay rogue waves my dudes it's
when it's when seemingly and seemingly
normal waves there's a frequency when
they can all just by some fluke of
statistics
we're like 50 waves wavelengths can line
up and make one mega wave out of the
ocean out of random and I'm telling I'm
not making them there's a well observed
phenomenon rogue waves there's videos of
it I swear to God go on google and type
a rogue wave in fact ela
why don't you do that and throw it on
the screen preg pregnant ass ela I don't
know what that means oh it's under it
goes on their ears
rogue waves guys oh this is stupid
I'm just waiting we gotta go to videos
how can I not click your screen can you
know this is confusing go to videos wait
wait
what has happened it just clicks really
low it's lagging okay here this one that
one looks to like click baby come on why
don't we have a block for Christ's day
would you want to show here okay
it's real I'm telling you do some
research go up there rogue waves they're
out there and you think you're safely on
the cruise you think those 1300 Indian
men with their balls out and in their
hotel room with the door open is bad
rogue waves my dude I don't know that
doesn't rogue waves me whatever I just
think that crazy me Taylor go open up
open a clip of cruise ship on on
troubled sea I'm telling you this shit's
amazing love like people getting like
tossed around with furniture and [ __ ]
it's amazing yeah he won't caught me
dead on those boats man apparently you
can gamble though Mike there's
prostitutes because it's legal that
sounds to bottle pick on Royal Caribbean
me I'm not on Royal Caribbean why not
unless you're with 1,300 Indians from a
tobacco company it's all my gamble
you're right about that
imagine the company brought like prepaid
prostitutes everyone's just taking a
turn what do we got here
[Music]
it's no sound all right but imagine
being on that that's a rogue wave my
dudes watch out for that all right any
rate we were watching the stand video
I'm getting on track here we got
important things to talk about obviously
and let's stay on track let's skip ahead
move into the voyages of the sleeves oh
because they would just stare and yeah
make us feel really uncomfortable the
family's got their two sinking feeling
from the push-off where we were seated
on that on the pool deck we were
actually asked to move we did because we
thought these people were from Royal
Caribbean but they were actually from
from the private party asking us to move
so they could
okay they're setting up for the sail
away party but I love how serious this
report is billick would you like the
comment to our role being newsroom and
the sail away put the shade roof of
these high jinks on the high seas is the
pool deck as one guy yes sweetie mess of
gyrating bodies I've never seen so many
mobile phones in my life really oh dear
God
yes Oh No anyway this feels you know but
um love it I just love the idea of 1300
Indian dude yeah taking on so much just
like what I don't know you got to love
it and this is you know this is the top
notch content that you can come to
expect here on the h3 podcast experience
okay there's one clip here that I
absolutely want to watch with you guys
and then we'll get some fan submissions
watch this and pasture claims I love
this clip so much I love these guys
he gets in front of his congregation he
says if you do not give 10% of your
whole income to the church you are
robbing God even if you are in debt what
do they call that a death a tilth
there's a saying it's oath if it's part
of high tithe of being Catholic or
Christian you're supposed to donate 10%
of your income to the church really man
ain't no [ __ ] church worth that send
me to hell I'm keeping that 10% I
already paid [ __ ] 50% to Uncle Sam
what does he do for me [ __ ] you kidding
me 10% is that all it takes to get into
heaven 10% [ __ ] it I'll go to hell
tithe is 10%
he says euro would be of both tithes and
offerings the 10% is what is yet what
God requires and then the offerings of
attempts to may require more than a 10%
somebody says I cannot cannot cannot
live on that I cannot live on 10% you
understand you may be deeply indented
being a real trouble
the it's gonna be hard for you to
believe but I'm telling you I'm singing
it over and over and over again you are
get out of this be run even with this
how you start mm-hmm
just start giving God 10% of your income
but there's no way I can do that just
try it just try it
I dare you kiss my guys like you don't
listen bring you all the time hmm there
you have it okay God cannot live on 10%
that's not weird cuz I've always like
seen like if I would go to a synagogue
when I was a kid with my mom they would
be like can you donate anything like
anything is a blessing yeah you mean
they have some staff some like like a
dollar some humility God cannot live
without yo 10% dear dear Jesus I
recently went out to lunch and I tipped
my sweet server
I gave him 20% now why don't I get 20%
Lord now I don't care if you're broke if
you're missing the kidney if you got
cancer
if you can't pay your debt boy I don't
give up I don't God doesn't care you
can't live on 10% but now if you want to
be good with Jesus you best be giving me
at least 10% of everything you weren't
boy cuz let me tell you what
ain't no 5% B buy me a private jet
because I got to pray all over this
country boy you think I cannot save on
5% people and that's right here in the
Bible that's that TIFF a tiff
no yes Jesus but help me Lord and how am
I supposed to afford these little tiny
crosses to mark the boys that I want to
molest yes Lord I need I feel that 10%
hmm preach if your kidneys failing boy
give me that kidney I'll sell it on the
black market that's 10% you good with
Jesus you know you need medicine to save
your life give me some of that medicine
I'll sell it on the black market 10%
while you feel me she get Amen mm-hmm
amen brother
oh you want me to give 10% cheated I'm
with the church I don't give 10% Dave
ain't give 10% I am God now let me touch
your kids dick hey man can I touch your
kids dick amen brother
hmm Jesus are you telling me that Jesus
didn't touch at least one baby penis at
least one I mean come on all right you
know Jesus at least look at a baby dick
am i right can I get an amen 10% by I
kid the Christians I could them they're
good people
what's going to defense there's one up
he was like though I kid I kid the
Christians they're good people
the Catholics they're great amen amen
I was researching with all these kind of
goofy pasture videos and there's just
one other one I want to show you guys
and ela you were gonna love this okay
this is incredible stuff in Capri
his name was Ben and I was running to
you but I was there for a few years and
he was a nice kid he's one of those kids
that was always just he's a real smart
aleck who was a bright kid which didn't
help things right made him more
dangerous we don't want you to think and
he was just just trying to push my
buttons and he was just you know kind of
not taking the Lord serious and I walked
over to him and I went I punched him in
the chest as hard as I crumpled the kid
I just claimed an brother I said I
leaned over I said Ben when are you
gonna stop playing games with God I let
that man to the Lord right there there's
that man's a lord right there mm-hmm
he's been in prison for 20 years now hmm
I love that you know everyone listening
was like what and I walked over to that
little 30-yard as I couldn't I laid him
out on the ground and I said boy when am
I getting that 10% because I know your
mama give you $5.00 a week in allowance
and to me that's 50 cents a week boy
where that 10% mmm that's when that boy
found God you've been in prison now for
20 years for murder that boy ain't right
I love that story man I love that story
anyway let's move it on to fan
submissions okay now this is podcast at
h3h3 productions dot-com
you guys can send in questions videos
comments whatever you want I love it
keep it coming
this is
so much fun so this one comes from
clammy hippo I wash a fruit podcast for
the same reason as everyone else to make
sure I have the correct opinion thank
you very much you do have the correct
opinion the recent debates on how you
wipe your arse
apparently this friend comes from across
the seas have been a mess immersive and
captivating and I wanted to slam-dunk a
lil debate here myself
do you piss in the shower I've asked
around and answers about 50/50 as a
proud shower piss or myself I need to
tell you I need you to tell me if I
should stop pissing the shower or carry
on just letting her rip
also on a little bit of a side note I'm
not sure there's a stupid question but
I'm sure you and everyone else does it
including me do you [ __ ] but do you [ __ ]
in the bath we simply need to know well
clammy hippo first let me start with the
first part because you took a quick turn
there peeing in the shower to me yes is
a beautiful natural thing it's like
peeing outside it's like it's a
beautiful thing where you don't I love
peeing in the shower I when I read this
I was shocked that why would you not pee
in the shower I pee on ela when we're in
the shower now Dan's acne and do you
guys pee in the shower you know I don't
go out of my way to but but sure I mean
I do if the if you go you hold it I
think I pee 100% of the time yeah every
other because you're relaxed it's warm
you're comfortable Ian in Zak do you pee
in the shower Zach says hell yeah no he
had he had recently such a contrarian
just like conscious like on yeah now why
do you not pee in the shower Dan and Ian
I mean I'm just do you think that but
yeah I mean apparently you go out of
your way to you like actually enjoy it I
do enjoy that we're not taking a bath
like if you're sitting in your own pee
in the bath I don't have you don't think
it's a bad Chris Evans takes a bath yeah
probably crafted that tweet while he was
in the bathtub peeing in it now and you
find it gross what is it about
peeing in the shower that that I have
roommates and it just doesn't seem
respectful really I who goes down with
the water who cares I don't know I just
yeah okay well I preach do you jerk off
in the shower
no because jerking off in the showers
[ __ ] nasty because it can get caught
in the drain gross and I've actually had
roommates where they jerk off in the
shower and you can see it in the drain
and that oh I'm telling you that [ __ ]
ain't right so I would say that jerking
off in the shower with roommates is is a
little stickier well it's none of that
is as bad as this guy's second but then
he says I'm sure there's a stupid
question I'm sure you and everyone else
does it including me but do you [ __ ] in
the bath now I think you know we won't
chain butter obviously [ __ ] in the
bath is I've not this person is not
serious you gotta be a sociopath yeah I
think you have to be homeless or so I
know how I don't know I would never
[ __ ] in the bath that can't be what
I'll tell you funny story about [ __ ]
in the bath though I had I live with two
dudes in college and we used to play a
game called do pee extreme where were
you tried to run an elaborate dupe on
one of the housemates that the other two
were on you would try to make them
believe some far-fetched outrageous
thing and so this was my crowning
achievement I would the other guy we
decided to try to convince our third
roommate who was kind of a germaphobe
that we [ __ ] in the shower and that it's
normal and everybody fits in the shower
so here's what I did this is fun I'm
proud of this way so I arranged it with
the other friend and then I called a
fourth friend and said hey we're doing
this prank I'm gonna call you and I want
you to say that you of course you should
[ __ ] in the shower so I was like I'll
bro um I was like hey just giving him
and I [ __ ] in the shower when I was in
there he's like you did what oh my god
this whole thing I was like yeah and you
[ __ ] in the shower I push it down with
my toes down the drain
it's normal my whole family everybody
does that and he's like he's like tell
me you guys are kidding he was like I
can you die
he was dead serious he was like tell me
you guys are [ __ ] kidding
like you don't [ __ ] the shower and then
my third roommate comes in he's like
yeah [ __ ] in the shower too you push it
down
he stomped it down with your toes and
he's like you guys are [ __ ] with me
and then we called up the fourth friend
and I was like I'm talking to Isaac
we [ __ ] in the shower and he doesn't
believe it but you shouldn't the shower
right he's like yeah everybody shits in
the shower
stomp it down with our toes and he's
sitting there having like a mental
breakdown like don't you have a name for
it like then we called it we did I don't
remember what
yeah the waffle stomp I think yeah we
called it a waffle stomp when you yeah
exactly
and so a waffle stop exactly so we
convinced him for a good like 20 minutes
that we waffle stump [ __ ] down the down
the drain so no I do not [ __ ] in the
bathtub and I sincerely do hope that you
do not shoot in the bathtub and nobody
fits in the bathtub because that ain't
sanitarian frankly you don't need to be
waffle stomping poop we have we have
systems plumbing in place to handle that
and I sincerely hope they use it so
thank you for the question submitted
from Danny Kelly this clip is just
[ __ ] amazing I've never seen this and
it's one of my favorite things I've ever
seen
I gave me so much joy and so much
laughter and I shared with you all today
[Applause]
bird [ __ ] [ __ ] mom how these shouting
a bird [ __ ] and his [ __ ] mouth
[ __ ] bird [ __ ] and ass [ __ ] mouth
[Laughter]
when are you gonna start taking Jesus
seriously
now give me 50 Cent's 10% I know that's
what Jesus wanted I think it said in the
Bible it said when disobedient crumpled
children with a powerful punch to the
gym this is a weirdo neelam run for the
cube you guys may remember him from my
recent or not h3 video we made about
this really weird head channel where
he's got this crazy voice but he
reviewed one of Ella's products and here
you go run for the cube I love I kind of
want to do a know you mean what this
[Music]
[ __ ] scares me make you feel being
and see what you're not going to open at
the boss how do you feel right now he
died freeze TTIP are just gone like an
ASMR Channel
with the tweezers just so weird the
gloves shiny bright like you mom
shiny bright like your mom I kind of
want to do I know you mean though I want
to try to reach out to him if you are
watching this which ever feeling he'll
see you this email us run the cube I
want to connect with you you're the
weirdest [ __ ] guy I've ever heard of
in my life but anyway he was very
gracious and he put a link in the
description and stuff so that was nice
but my god I I'm scared of him
he's got a nice following like 70,000
views but is that his normal viewer
siblings
let me take a look kind of used this guy
usually pull this is the weird it's us
as this trailer what the [ __ ] we've ever
seen channel name is run for the cube it
should be my I'm getting I'm like you've
got him I'm funny man
oh he hasn't made a video and this was
the last video he made two months ago
and then six months after that holy [ __ ]
this guy is obsessed with us here mm-hm
we're in his trailer his last video he
made he's hunting us down with those
tweezers and gloves on cube run for your
life
rent just take out the queue by the
trailer were different on you oh man I
guess run for the cube watch people kind
of talking about this phenomenal hey
yeah yeah II run from that you know that
was crazy
there you have it did that make a meal
he reviewed your I guess honored honored
cool and then ela did you want to talk
about the riff did Teddy fresh Club yeah
so there is a ribbon dip and Teddy fresh
collab which is crazy
you got pics yeah it's under there
under your video where's my and here's
our model that's me I said to EULA thank
you for being progressive in using a
plus-size model we all really appreciate
that and so this will be coming out next
week do not have a better picture of the
knot right before the close-up there you
go and I just wanted to say that we're
gonna be doing a meet-and-greet in their
store in LA on Sunset Boulevard no
Fairfax Avenue that you just type rip
and dip in there yeah yeah but what is
it it's Saturday at 11:00 a.m. they're
gonna sew a limited amount we're talking
about the 13th of October right yeah so
noon Saturday October 13th 441 North
Fairfax Avenue we will be there slinging
some teddy fresh and rippin dip and then
I will be dropped online the next day
Sunday on their website now I'm excited
oh I love it man it came out so good
this is their their mascot the cat yeah
so the cat and the bear teamed up and
they're crushing it then and finally
thank you to all of our sponsors we have
a little sponsor button on YouTube that
you can smash to support us thank you
very much to those of you who have done
that thank you everyone who has a watch
to the podcast will love you so very
much thank you Ian for the presentation
thank you to Kanye very cool
and have a blessed Friday that's about
it right I mean there's a I mean I said
right you know yeah I mean there's more
stuff but it's close - yeah it's we're
closed for two hours I start to lose
steam at two hours two hours gets mad
that's when I start talking about like
pedophile priests and stuff and it was
like
we already snuck in the music oh you
already plant you're already playing me
off
well guys join us next Friday for
another episode
eel is pregnant she still be pregnant
probably or not so weird I don't know
I'm just saying that he looks so stupid
I'm being played off right now I know
that I can't hear the music but my
family was like no don't say anything
till 10 weeks yeah it's like come on my
family said don't say anything till four
months I say don't say anything till the
baby comes yeah that's like halfway
there I say don't say anything until a
year to make sure the baby's healthy you
know we're in this journey together
we've been very vocal about the process
so we don't see any reason not to
continue that trend guys next week we'll
hear again have a blessed beautiful
Friday evening the weekend is upon us we
made it thank God it's Friday and
remember to give 10% boy otherwise
you're gonna get punched in the chest by
your pasture thank you for watching have
a blessed beautiful weekend and remember
this save Papa John calm
all right working
[Music]